呃，先说一下这部电影啊，小丑。
嗯，选这部电影有几个原因。第一个原因呢是小丑被呃被大家很关注啊，特别是嗯咱们年轻人文艺青年啊，在小丑上的时候都是。
呃，很多人都都看到过他的信息，甚至去捧过场是吧？
这部电影可以说是这几年算是比较现象级的一次事件吧啊，所以说这这。
嗯，第二个。
原因呢就是嗯当时其实大家都会捏一把汗，对吧？男主角华金能不能超越原版小丑啊，在蝙蝠侠里面的那个小丑。
那个形象不管是从。
演技上还是说从整个悲情色彩上，因为之前那个小丑那个演员他。
和他。
也过世了嘛，自杀了啊。
所以说呃这也是很奇怪的一个现象啊。如果一个一个。
一个演员或者一个艺术家英年早逝的话，大家会把他的。
呃，呃遗留的作品。
会抬的比较高啊。嗯，所以说当时蝙蝠侠那一版的小丑号称无法超越了啊，定义了小丑。当然了，那一版非常好，所以说就导致大家对这个凤凰叔非常捏一把汗啊。因为嗯他的职业生涯其实很完美啊，挑战过各种各样的角色。
嗯，他挑战这一版小丑，可以说是呃非常的出人意料啊就是。
非常勇敢啊，想去挑战一个特别经典的角色，非常完美的这个演绎了这一版小丑。而且他做出了非常大的自我牺牲啊，他为了追求角色这个状态啊，把自己的体重控制到一个非常极限的状态，那个胸骨都外翻了啊嗯控制的非常极限的一个状态，对自己身体伤害也比较大。所以说这一版。
那小丑值得我们尊重啊，咱们开始上课。这部电影非常明显啊，它的特点非常明确啊，一个反派的诞生。我们说DC要拍这部电影，嗯，他的交给导演的任务，或者交给这个编剧，交给主创的任务，肯定就是。
给我写小丑的诞生。我们说资方给到这些创作者的要求，肯定是角色已经有了，就是这个希斯台街版的小丑，对吧？你们现在给我塑造这个角色的诞生，一个坏蛋的诞生，是吧？那么从创作者的角度，他能想到哪些办法呢？
你们觉得他完成这个任务了吗？
我说一下我的观点啊。
我觉得完成了啊，完你了写了一个小丑呃的诞生啊，一个人物的诞生，甚至丰富了这个角色的一些内涵。比如说他爱笑这件事情，对吧？给他加了一个病症。
比如说嗯他的身世啊，他和那个这个城市的纠葛啊。
以及他如何成为。
坏蛋们的一个偶像或者icon啊，他是如何接受这个icon的？我觉得完成的还是。
嗯，非常圆满啊。那我们来看一下这部戏的信息节拍啊，最近韩国片国产片嗯好莱坞片儿我们都看啊，大家有没有一个感觉，就是嗯好莱坞片它的他们相对的信息量比较大，大家有没有发现这个问题？
不管从节拍的密度，还是说单拍的信息量，一般来说啊，好莱坞电影比较追求大的信息量啊。
韩国电影介于之间啊借于之间。
看一下这部电影的。
信息拍。
第一排啊。
我们说在。
第一拍展现主角的现状，展现的是什么现状呢？他在他的工作的后台化妆间啊，然后呢展示他的工作是什么？我们说上来展示主角的现状以及主角的一个肥皂泡啊，他是他本来就活在面具之下才能找到他的。
很愉快的生活，因为很轻快的音乐，说明他还是很喜欢这份工作的啊。
然后呢呃新闻的这个新闻音啊作为一个背景。
然后但是他在工作中被欺负被殴打是一个常态啊，所以说他虽然很。
很喜欢自己做小丑这份工作。
但是呢社会依然毒打他啊。
第二拍来到第4分钟。
开始展现他的大笑这件事情啊，但是呃这里还没有说明原因。然后是一个什么场景呢？是一个社工做心理辅导的场景啊，也就是说社区的一个心理疏导员会定期访问这个社区的一些啊这个这个弱势群体也好，或者特殊群体也好啊，我们说这是一个很美式文化的一个东西。
在很多呃美美剧美美国电影里面都有啊，嗯算是他们的一种一种一种管理方式吧。
第三拍来了第8分钟啊，回家的公交车上。
嗯，想逗小孩啊想逗小孩玩，嗯，想救猫咪来着展现一下他对小朋友其实很友善，但是被误解了啊呃，然后拿出一个卡片展现他的那个疾病啊。因为上一拍他刚刚大效果，让我们观众看的头摸不着摸不着头脑。
呃，但是由于不是一个悬疑片，像这种悬念啊没有必要放很久。在下一篇立即。
立即就解开了，我这么说能明白吗？
我们说这不是一个悬疑片啊，像他大笑，是一个疾病这件事情，像这种无效悬疑没有必要拉很久啊。我们说在第二拍展现了之后，第三拍马上又出现这个问题，马上拿出一个卡片说这是一种疾病完事儿啊。而而且这一拍主要是为了展现救猫咪未遂啊，救猫咪未遂。第四拍。
来到第9分钟，我们说前面几拍就是展现现状的啊，工作展现了呃人设。我们说第二拍通过心理辅导，通过社社工的心理辅导是为了干什么啊？是为了补充人设啊。我们说第二拍那里补充人设，通过对话快速大量补充人设，你的理想是什么？你对社会的观点是什么，对吧？
你对人生的观点是什么？脱口秀演员是吧？对对生活的悲观都在那补充人设啊。
好，来到第四拍，第9分钟继续展现现状，展现是什么家庭。
然后家庭里面有什么呀？
有孝顺父母，他不是说接着上上牌，他不是说哎想当脱口秀演员吗？对吧？展现一下脱口秀。
看透的就节目。同时他也回忆了一下以前的一些。
我们来看一下这边。
他对妈妈还是很孝顺的对吧？照顾自己的母亲这种都是小细节。他妈妈每天要让他看信箱，看有没有人回信，对吧？他说没有nothing.
其实是想后面是有兑现的，是因为他妈妈每天给市长写信是吧？
还有是定还是什西，有 ready分。
兄体。
他不会思吹吹哪。
Some special author I can tell where from?
甚至这个呃想象啊想象自己呃跟明星的互动啊，想象明星发现自己。我们说从这里啊。
大家先听我说啊，记笔记啊，我提前说一下这部电影。
共情力为什么很强？是因为它里面确实有很多我们普通人的想象。
甚至我们普通人在这个很艰难的社会里面生存的时候，我们残存的一些想象。
比如说我们会想象。
有有权势的人注意到我。
我们会想象，对吧？
如果那个全程最富的人是我爹多好，对吧？我们会想象。
我们的。
妈妈是无条件爱着我们的对吧？我们会想象。
隔壁的那那个女孩。
是喜欢我的。
我们会想象。
这个努力工作诚实的工作。
是会有回报的。
是吧。
当这些想象一一被现实摧毁的时候。
一个好人也就崩溃了。
如果一个人的所有梦想。
喜欢的女孩爱自己，妈妈爱自己，自己的才华得到认可，对吧？我们说这些想象。
不算特别过分的想象，如果全都被无情的揭穿，那么一个好人也就崩溃了。
这是整个电影的一个叙事路径。你把这个装进脑子里面，再跟着我看所有的节拍，你就明白了。
你把这个装进自己的脑子里面啊，然后再去看整个片子的叙事，你就明白他为什么要这么写。
那所以在第四拍里，他会想象我的才华，我也有这样的才华。同学们，你们有没有无数次看在电视里面的某个主持人或者某个演员，你会觉得我的才华其实和他差不多或者比他好，他为什么赚那么多钱？
对吧。
所以说像这种这种戏啊非常明确啊非常明确，没有什么奇怪的。好，第五拍。
15分钟。
工作环境。
回到工作环境啊。
一个同事给了他一把枪，打破平衡了啊。然后但是在这个时候，他被老板克扣工资，他也只敢偷偷发泄啊。第六拍来了20分钟。
电梯里。
一对友善的黑人母女。
是他生活的唯一色彩。
啊，第七拍21分钟。
嗯，继续交代给家庭啊，给给妈妈洗澡啊，交代他的家庭。他其实从没长大啊，我们说妈宝男妈宝男然后嘞把完手枪的时候还走火了。我们说他第一次体验到了开枪的感感觉啊。我们说这部片子啊，他整个打破平衡的就是这把枪啊。
他本来是没有机会反抗的，第八拍来了24分钟。
偷窥和跟踪那对那个友善的母女啊，另外也偷偷学习脱口秀技巧。
我们说为什么把这两件事情放在一起呢？
因为这是他生活两大寄托啊两因为这个时候他还不知道那个所谓的市长嗯，是他父亲当然了，也是他妈想象的啊，所以他现在生活最大的寄托是什么？
在第一幕里面，目前他生活最大的寄托。
就是爱情和事业。而且他在意淫的过程中，这里还意淫了一个场景。也就是说她用笑话征服了这个美女啊，在她的想象当中，她用笑话征服了这个美女。
我们来看一下啊。
典型的一个还蛮朴素的梦想啊，并并不过分。
Can you following me today.
coming around the place.
应对。
另外呃点com一些这个东西甩身。
他该怎呢。
你怎没就问嗯。
第九拍28分钟在儿童医院表演啊，这场戏我们都记得手枪脱落啊，被开除了，搞出事情了。同时他也发现自己被自己的同事给陷害了啊，人家给他这把枪就没安好心啊，没安好心。我们说啊在这里啊他发现呃身边人的恶意。
好，第1拍来到30分钟。
地铁上。
呃，几个小混混呃调戏妇女啊，调戏妇女呃，他的这个疾病又犯了啊，大笑这件事情又犯了，打断了对方，导致了冲突。然后那几个小混混揍他，然后呢，被迫拿出枪，枪杀了对方，枪杀了对方。
我们说在这里啊开始算是开始反击了，第十拍能理解吧？这里刚开始反击啊，开始反击了。
1一拍34分钟，那那那杀了人啊，他开始逃跑躲藏啊，躲起来之后呢，竟然逐渐体验到了一种释放和爽感啊。
在这里可以总结成5个字儿，做坏人真香。
从十一拍啊，他一他竟然体会到了真香啊，名茶面我们看一看啊。
开始是逃跑的。
做坏人真香以后，呃，这个游戏时光啊，游戏时光就就就正式开始了啊，甚至艺淫自己跟这个女邻居都亲上了。
第十2拍36分钟，意淫自己和女邻居亲热。2了，很多同学说我不觉得这里是意淫。没错呀，从叙事的角度，这里这里还没说是意淫吗。
好不好？很多同学说这里不是意淫，这么理解是可以的嘛。因为在故事讲到这里的时候，我们还没有明说是意淫嘛。
所以你可以理解从叙事的角度来说，做了坏人以后啥都好了。
腰不疼了，腿不酸了，做了坏人以后哎。
我的精神内卷就就精神内耗多好了，甚至还泡到妞了。
不用把这里理解为想象，就是我突然发现做坏，我开始做好人嘛，我勤勤松恳的工作，然后孝孝敬孝敬父母。
开始的时候是这样的，然后从第二幕不小心盖死几个人之后哎。
我发现哇哇做坏人真香啊，13拍37分钟回到工作地点啊，继续享受暴复和暴力带来的快感啊。他现在已经谁都不处了啊，爱开出我不开除我，他开始这种暴复和暴力的这种快感，继续享受1四拍38分钟啊。
看电视，他发现啊呃自己的价值观不被认可啊。呃这里当然是埋一个小伏笔，竞选市长的那个人不认可自己的价值观。
15拍来到40分钟，又是一场社工心理辅导。
他发现这群人对自己的关心都是假的，什么什么药也也不给了啊，他让他更坚定了。
他更坚定了自己的道路，也就是做坏人这条路，他已经他更坚定了这件事情。16拍41分钟啊，参加open麦。
参加op朋麦啊大笑出丑，但是自我感觉很良好啊，他甚至有了成功的假象，什么报得美人归，收获粉丝自我实现走向巅峰，是吧？
十7拍48分钟啊。
偷看母亲写给父亲的信啊，也就是写给维恩的信，呃，发现了自己的一些身世线索。
和母亲争吵啊和母亲争吵。他在这时候发现哎市长是我爹啊，十八拍51分钟，他有了一个新的目标去找爹。
然后跑到人家家里，隔着大铁门，逗人家的小孩玩，被驱赶，被否认。
十九拍55分钟，母亲病重啊，母亲在目前是他生活的呃极大寄托之一啊，病重。然后当然了，这里也伴随着警察对他的一些盘问啊。这个之前他杀人这件事情还是有一些线索落下了。
但是他好在还有女友的陪伴啊，呃想象中的女朋友20拍60分钟。
发现自己。
在节目呃被偶像在节目里调侃了，又一个希望崩塌了。
我们说整个就是希望和崩塌的过程啊。
21拍61分钟。
呃，发现自己引发了革命，这件事情还是让他很满很很满意的啊，享受胜利很满意的。
22拍63分钟混进电影院啊，开始接近他爹。
然后呢，在厕所向父亲表白被拒，不光被剧还被揍了是吧？好像好像还被揍了一拳啊，又这是他生活的又一个希望啊。
然后23拍68分钟啊，又燃起一个新的希望，受邀参加偶像的综艺节目。
是吧。
24拍70分钟去医院调查母亲当年的线索啊，因为他爹不认他嘛，去调查当年的线索，发现真相之后非常的失望啊，抢走了报告，甚至回忆当年也就是说他那个人根本不是他父亲啊，是他妈意淫出来的，而且他妈小时候呃也对他非常不好啊，是非常不好。
25拍来了76分钟，下着雨的夜啊，他这时候妈也。
不对路子，父亲也是假的。嗯，偶像在综艺节目里面还调侃自己。虽然在这之前邀请自己参加综艺节目了，但是我们后面知道啊呃他其实去的时候就已经打算在节目里面搞事情了，他带枪去的嘛。所以说。
在25拍下着一个雨的夜啊，他只能去找谁呀？
只能找自己现在唯一的希望了啊，他现在唯一的希望就是他还有个女朋友嘛，还有个对象。
唯一的希望是还有个对象啊，我们来看一下这场戏76分钟。唯一的这时候唯一的希望还有个对象呢。
我们说这场戏表示，那那想象中的女友啊基本上就挂了啊。总之啊他这里啊，他把这个呃女邻居杀了啊。
然后第26拍80分钟到医院，又把自己的母亲给杀了啊。
27拍。
82分钟啊，在家里练习，他最后还有个事儿没完成嘛？我们说还有个期待没完成，没兑现呢，就上节目嘛，对吧？他在练习上节目的细节，在这里我们发现啊他是准备在节目当中自杀的。他是本来是准备在节目直播当中因为他之前说嘛，他的死可能更有意义。
啊，有些人的生可能没有意义，但是死可以比生更有意义。那么他在最开始的时候，在第一场戏里面就有就有这件事情。所以他准备在节目当中自杀啊嗯。
28拍来到85分钟啊，同事来访同事来访，他把这个同事报仇啊杀了，因为他现在已经。
因为他现在已经疯了啊，已经疯了。
啊，当然了，在这里杀人的时候，他放走了一个。
一个侏儒啊，因为他说那是唯一一个对他好的人啊，对他好的人。很多同学不理解啊，说为什么小丑。
把女邻居给杀了，把妈妈都给杀了，但是会放过一个跟她同事过的侏儒。
同学们是这样啊。
在极端人的心态里。
实际上，他对母亲是怨恨的。
他对那个小侏儒没有怨恨。
但是他对那些不爱他的人是有怨恨的。
29拍90分钟啊，一个名场面啊，他这个配上这个BGM啊，配上BGM。
然后穿上战袍奔赴直播啊，奔赴直播，同时也展现了全程都是小偷啊，甚至追他的警察都被被打啊，被杀。我们说这也是一个名场面啊，看一眼。
这场戏是一个名场面啊。好，这一拍结束之后啊，来到30拍95分钟正式参加节目啊，正式参加节目。在节目当中面对羞辱啊，痛斥了一切，并且临时改变了主意，也不自杀了啊，把那个把那个主持人给杀了啊，那个主持人给杀了。
呃，因为他说嗯。
没有什么。
可失去的了，现在已经没有人能伤害自己了，他把能杀害自己的人都杀杀光了啊，没有人能伤害自己。
他认为自己被伤害了，才会做这些事情啊，我们看一下。
他想象这个演播室想象过很多次了啊，因为嗯我们刚才说过，普通人确实是会幻想，站在工众面前，嗯，被自己仰视的人认可啊，确实会经常想象这种空空间这种场景，甚至想象自己领奖，想象自己上己上节目，对吧？
Tell us about this look. When you earlier, you mentioned that this look is not a political statement. All right, That very not political. I just trying to make people wife and a second.
又看了一遍这句话，我只希望我的死更有价值。
但更我。
女孩来了。
他跳过了这个笑话，他决定不杀自己了。its the policeman dead.
,, no, no you cannot talk about that. Yeah, that's not funny., that's the kind of humor we do on the show. Okay, I Yeah I'm sorry, it's just, you know, it's been a few weeks, Mu ever since I.
Kill usly Wallt Street guys.
我改2080万。
拿了这个。
上去当 kill you man on the subway and why should we believe it.
那是给他个名吗？
My life is nothing a comedy.
Let' get this straight. You think that killing those guys is funny. I do and I'm tired of pretending it's not. you subject, what they say all of you, the system that knows so much you decide what's right or wrong the same way that you decide what's on or not.
Okay, I think I might understand that you movement to become a their why is so guys sidewalk.
You have a problem with Thomas Wayne. Yes, I do. Have you seen what it's like out there, Marray, Do you ever actually leave the studio. Everybody just yells and screams at each other. Nobody selling anymore. Nobody thinks what it's like to be the other guy.
If they meant like Thomas Wayne, everything would fight to be someone like me, to be somebody but themselves, they don't. They think that we'll just sit there and like good little boys that we won't world the wild. I mean much self p making excuse for those young men, not everybody I'll tell you there'.
哎，我我要上朋友。
对个。
你说应该是。
You just wanted to make fun of me.
Just like the rest of them, youre not first thing about you about. Look at that because is what you did. what alleged you, your riots out there to police in critical condition. You're laughing. You're laughing. Someone was killed today because of what you did. I know.
。
回什么拜来。
这拍非常精彩啊。好，来到山西一拍106分钟啊，刚才这拍11分钟，他名声大噪啊，因为在直播里面办大事了啊，名声大噪，影响力也大增。然后呢，导致全城的很多效仿者啊都在跟在他后面进行用暴力手段去对抗。嗯，他们认为可以对抗的东西。
然后虽然他被警察带走啊。
但是他的警车被阻拦了，被被被营救，他逃脱了出来。呃，他让所所有人都成为了小丑。32拍啊呃110分钟全程暴动。那个市长，也就是他的那个假父亲啊，他他以为韦恩是他父亲嘛。
嗯，也被杀了啊也被杀了。
33块110分钟嗯，很有嗯111分钟啊，很有代表性的一场结尾戏，他在烈火当中重生了。
凤凰你也盘了一场戏啊，然后故事的34拍啊，第三次面对这个所谓的心理评估。我们说评估结束之后呢，他又把这个评估员给杀了啊，暗示他逃了出去呃，成为了一个反派啊。因为我们说这个电影讲的是反派的诞生嘛。
所以说呃他在这里在结尾这场戏没有关注他啊，他逃掉了，他把这个人杀了之后逃掉了，我们看一下。
哇 so funny。
那开口。
这事。
伤害了这个工作人员之后，呃，后面阳光从窗外洒进来啊，代表他逃掉了。这个结尾还是虽然用金色的阳光，但是结尾非常阴暗啊。呃小丑诞生了这个反角儿呃，逍遥法外啊，看一下这个镜头。好，我们说一下这个电影啊。
首先。
这部电影是典型的反套路电影啊，是以一个坏人为主角，因为要讲这个坏人的诞生，讲因果，所以呢又显得大家还能共情他，对吧？这就是这种电影的难度啊，以及嗯富有争议和魅力的地方啊，讲一个坏人的诞生，还让大家理解他。
那显然这种电影呃从。
审查的角度。
肯定是过不了的啊，所以刚才我看评论区里有一位同学呃对这个电影传达的这个这个主题啊非常的抵触。对，是这样的啊。因为像这种电影在咱们国内的审查肯定是过不了的啊，肯定是过不了的。呃，怎么能讲社会把一个好人逼成坏人呢，对吧？是不可以的。呃，但是我们为什么要看这部电影呢？因为我们拉片学习要全面的学习。
我再次强调一下啊，你欣赏一个呃文艺作品，一个故事，你未必要认可它的价值观啊，这个事情是可以分开的。就好像我们去看那个哎有很多电影是抢银行的，其实很过瘾的啊，我们说那种电影，我们看了以后也未必会去抢银行嘛，或者是我们生活当中我们也不抢银。
但是抢银行的电影还是可以看的嘛，对不对？再比如说盗墓笔记对吧？盗墓笔记这个像这种电影啊，都是从从价值观的角度，你没有必要去认可它啊。但是可以看吧，好吧，然后呢我们说一下这部电影啊，其实我当时看的时候有一个非常大的感受啊。
就是关于。
在原版角色当中，就希斯莱杰那个版的小丑。
他为什么扮成小丑？是因为他的继父嫌他成天摆一张臭脸，用刀给他把嘴划开了。记不记得有谁记得这个细节？说实话，我觉得这个设定好屌。
没用，我觉得挺可惜，围绕这个实际上是可以做点故事啊。
我们来看一下这部片子，它整个脉络啊，看起来是在报复啊，是在报仇，对吧？很多同学会觉得这是一部报复的片子。但实际上我们理完之后，我在开篇的时候就跟你跟大家说过，他其实它的脉络是什么？它的脉络是一个人的希望。
不断的破灭的过程。同学们，你们数一数都有哪些希望？有些希望是本来就有的，有些希望是后来发生的。
都有哪些希望？我们说事业就有两个吧，他原本的工作以及我们说家庭、母亲的爱，想象中的父亲、爱情、邻居，然后社会层面还想希望得到高人的提写，就是因为这些东西让我们每个人产生了共情。
我再次强调啊，我们不需要去同情一个坏人。
但是在艺术作品当中，你要知道他们就是这么玩的。
而且刚才有有个同学说的很非常好啊，小丑就是我们自己啊，小丑就是在我们身边，只不过我们没有杀人嘛，我们没有选择杀人。或许有些同学在头脑中在特别气愤，特别怨恨的时候，在头脑当中想象过。
杀死谁或者杀死对面的某个人，想象过而已。
所以我们有些时候是能共情这个小丑。
明白吗？
不需要去做坏人。
但是某些程度的共情是可以做的，不是说哎。
这个人有些事情我能共情到，就代表你赞同他，这是两回事情。
我给大家讲两个细节啊，就这里面的情况我遇到过两个就是。
小丑。
特别希望那个murory那个角色，mory那个角色是一个著名的主持人。
小丑主持人都是脱口秀演员出身。
所以m那个我们的主角特别希望murray能够。
认可他提携他同学们，这件事情我也遇到过。
大家都知道我讲编剧课啊。
我估计我见过咱们的学生啊，见过学生很多啊，专门找到我。
来拜访我的学生，我觉得至少有10个就专门我没有约他，我也不认识他，专门来找到我的学生差不多有10个。
他们每个人见我的时候呢，都非常激动。
都会告诉我他们有多喜欢我，以及他们对艺术有多热爱，有多努力。
然后呃会当场给我看。
嗯，他们的作品。然后在我接待完他们以后，离开了，有一半以上对我破口大骂，真的是破口大骂，有多难听，骂多难听啊，有一半有一半吧，骂的你就甭提有多难听了，有的还骂很久啊，因为他发现。
我并没有立刻马上的欣赏他，没有立刻马上让他成为。
他想成为的人。
骂我有眼无珠之类的啊。
这个情况我遇到过太多次了，所以我从那以后很少愿意见这种远道而来的学生啊，远道而来的学生。
因为他们他们会专门找上门来，然后他们认为他们距离他们想要成为的那个人就差一个mory。但实际上成功不是那么简单的啊。所以说你像这种时刻可包括我们说小丑啊，我们还是强调那句话，我们不认可这个价值观啊，但是这种现象，我们是可以。
啊，可以借鉴。我们在日常生活当中写这种角色的机会不多，除非是写电视剧，对吧？写电视剧是会用到这种。
反派的诞生的，比如说那个高启强，比如说高启强啊，那我们在写这种角色的时候，一个坏人诞生的时候啊，我不推荐大家写电影。
但是如果在长剧当中塑造一个。
这个令人印象深刻的反派是可以的。我再说一遍啊，我们写这种角色的时候，电影我就不推荐了啊，真的过不了。
但是电视剧是可以的那我们就学习一下这种电影的写法啊，叫一个坏人的诞生这种电影的写法。
两个两个核心要素啊，第一个核心要素。
你给我把这部片子结合这部片子，再结合我们自己的生活，给我把一个人在生活当中那些最美好、最淳朴、最强烈的期待。
那些希望给我写出来。
然后一一戳破，一一让它毁灭反爽文啊反爽文。你想象的那些好事儿，所有能发生在你身上的美好，甚至本来就属应该属于你的那些美好，全部给你撕毁。在这部电影当中也不就也不就也不就写了六七个吗？
你在塑造会人的时候，你也写他六七个七八个，好吧。
这是第一点，就写一个坏人的诞生啊，你可以用在电视剧当中，电影我不推荐。第一点给我先整理这个。
第二点，大环境和小环境相结合，否则还是容易让大家很难共情。因为毕竟写坏人嘛，大环境跟小环境相结合，小环境是你自己的那大环境呢？大环境是啥？我们说这部电影当中大环境就是这个城市很腐败，大家日子过得并不好。
当然了，这是一个虚拟的城市，我们共情不到。我们回到高启强，高启强的大环境是什么？高启强那个戏的大环境是什么？私人承包，对吧？然后还有拆迁，那些大家是能共情的呀。所以你如果要写一个角色。
你这个角色肯定有他的小环境，对吧？有他的爱情，他的父母，他的工作，但是大环境是什么？大环境你能想到的大环境能够逼风一个人的大环境，还有什么？我们说高启强用的是什么拆迁欺行霸士什么的，一定要小环境跟大环境相结合。
大环境什么失业自己想嘛啊，其实还是好多的啊，还是好多可以写的啊嗯。
自己想一个大环境，把整个事件装在一个大的背景下啊，整个大的事儿也让人气愤。大环境和小环境同时让人气愤，双向发力。具体这个例子你们自己找吧，也太多了吧。我只能说这也解释了很多同学说哎，为什么这个戏有那么多想象，是因为那些美好的事情不可能真的发生吗？
你待会儿一定要戳破的，你要都真的发生过，那后面咋解释嘛？我来说一下这个片子的结构啊，一般来说啊，像这种片子讲诞生的，它整体上来说应该算是小丑整个的第一幕啊，实际上来说应该是第一幕。当然这个片子里面还是有比较明确的三幕式啊，第一幕当然是。
他隐忍了生活啊，然后呃踏上第二幕是什么呢？也就是他开始报复啊，开始开始反击吧。也就是说。
然后最后一幕是第三幕啊，是呃他开始呃号召整个社会啊号召整个社会进行反击。我说这个结构还是基本上还是有的。但是严格来说，像这种电影啊，实际上是讲小丑的希望不断的破灭，然后让他。
走出第一幕的这种整个来说是是有这个作用的啊，讲它的诞生的好吧，所以说这个三幕分的不那么明显，或不是不那么明显啊，不那么规整，我们是可以容忍的，好不好？好，今天这部电影啊比较有争议，确实比较有争议的电影。但是由于确实引起了比较大的反响。
不管是从商业上，还是从艺术成就上，那咱们就是今天学一学啊，好吧。好，同学们，咱们下节课见啊。
拜拜各位。